PATRICK CLARY:
There are estimated
to be 35 million
people in the US
with some level of
motor impairment.
Designing your application to
support accessibility services
not only opens up your
application to these users,
but it has the
potential to improve
your design for everyone.
Users with motor impairments
have a wide range
of conditions, including
spinal cord injuries,
multiple sclerosis,
ALS, cerebral palsy,
essential tremor,
and Parkinson's.
These users may find it
difficult to use a touch
screen, particularly if your
app relies on small touch
targets or complex gestures.
Google has developed the
accessibility services Switch
Access and Voice Access in
order to provide these users
with alternate means of
operating their devices.
With Switch Access, users press
one or more physical hardware
buttons to scan through
items on their screen
and select the one they want.
Voice Access lets users speak
their commands to the device
in order to tap,
scroll, or enter text.
OK, Google, start Voice Access.
Go home.
Open phone.
Click 17.
Go home.
Tap 8.
Go back.
Swipe right.
By keeping a few design
considerations in mind,
you can radically
transform the quality
of user interaction
between your app
and Switch Access
and Voice Access.
A Switch Access user usually
scans the screen from top
to bottom.
Therefore, it's a good
idea to keep elements
on the screen
logically organized.
Small touch targets can be
difficult for users to select,
so we recommend that touch
targets be at least 48
by 48 dp.
In addition, users
can have difficulty
interacting with
touch targets that
are closely grouped together.
Therefore, we suggest
having low density layouts.
Ensure that clickable and long
clickable items are correctly
labeled and that the clickable
attribute hasn't been added
to any non-clickable items.
You can easily try out
Switch Access in your own app
by going to Settings,
Accessibility, Switch Access,
opening Switch Access
settings, and then
by assigning a volume
key to act as a switch.
You can also use a USB
or Bluetooth keyboard.
Then, ensure that you
can perform every action
in the app with the switch.
Make sure that each item
can be scrolled through,
and it is clear
what each one does.
To learn more about Switch
Access or Voice Access,
check out these links at
developer.android.com.
You should also consider
watching our video
on developing for users
with visual impairments.
[MUSIC PLAYING]